[Music]
i thought you could talk to me yeah
things
[Music]
i'll just have to think of something
else here i thought you could talk to me
[Music]
what's up
will that be all
actually
i really like the shirt that you're
wearing do you have any of those around
no we don't have it here it's only
available at crowdershop.com
it's this nazi show that i watch
ironically everybody who has anything to
do with it is a racist
so you're ironically racist to wearing a
swastika it's hilarious
[Music]
stupid
in that case.com
[Applause]
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool reds
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
first
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
delicious sip and you know i'm just i'm
like a dog right now quarter black's
watch is reflecting in the studio i
apologize
of time
i am very easily distracted that's a cat
it's a new watch for more on that is it
i don't know is it no i haven't well
it's a good it's my daily did you buy it
uh the point is i'm a child
easily distracted that's how you know
your job is not very important if i can
uh be distracted by the reflection of a
watch that's likely always been there
it's been there for a while
we should do this
sketch and just like yeah get you um we
have a lot we'll be talking about today
before we get to that look a little
later on in the show i want to warn you
uh it'll sound nerdy because we're
talking about the fda uh effectively
threatening to ban what is potentially a
coveted therapeutic treatment i don't
know according to the fda they're saying
this isn't a supplement anymore it's a
drug the issue the reason that i want to
talk about this with you i just ask that
you give me a little bit of grace
because i have to get into a little bit
of science um
is because
if
if we can help the millions of you out
there by simply discussing something
that is safe potentially effective or
even help you by letting you know that
you are not allowed to receive this
information i feel like we have an
obligation to do it and right now
everyone on this platform on youtube and
many of you are watching on rumble thank
you that's why we recommend you
subscribe on on apple uh on spotify uh
we'll be showing some clips from when we
were banned on youtube not long ago yeah
i can tell you this the tenor behind the
scenes not just here everyone is afraid
to discuss things that are not
controversial
because youtube facebook twitter
they're they're it's not a conspiracy
they're in cahoots with the fda and cdc
and the information changes and that's
how you fight like hell look a lot of
people saying what do you do let's just
stop going along with any of it and so
it starts today talking about a
potential covid therapeutic that just
went into we found out phase two trials
oh wow wow could have bought a fine trap
yesterday now you can't phase two trials
so uh variants not a conspiracy not
frogs becoming gay though i think we're
gonna have stones on the show soon uh
we'll also be talking about uh the late
night hosts who all came together last
night
for climate change is that why it was so
nice out today yes
yes they did it it was uh who knew the
polar vortex was affected by unfunny i
had no idea
it's the l non-comedy effect
it's the rat costume and traffic effect
that cures every time seth meyers tells
a joke a school of humboldt squid die
uh gerald day how are you i am well how
are you i'm doing fine some people are
better some peruvian fishermen know
about the humboldt square they do yeah
and they care about that
they appear and disappear we don't know
where they go quarter black oh what's up
good morning least black hair i've ever
seen deal with it and dave you're going
to be in albany uh this friday and
saturday albany new york that's right at
the funny bone ahoy ahoy funny bone and
come out and see me say hi
you can cough on uh you can cough in his
direction yeah just cough all over me
yeah i like a good covered cough all
over my body if you get it to transmit
it oh yeah
uh i'll wear a mask so it won't matter
before we get into this and what the
late night hoes have been doing in a big
what i think is a big deal with the fda
uh we do need to react uh now um
what is this serious this is seriously
serious uh apparently before and after
pictures yeah it's uh i don't know if
it's a it's a pandemic oh yes it's a
phobic pandemic
i've heard it's an endemic now well
that's edema that comes with oh the
before picture i gotta stop using those
yes my bathroom has been painted again
[Laughter]
uh here you go this is what went viral
this morning when diet culture or
personal trainers say take progress
photos to stay on track what they're
actually doing is perpetuating the idea
lie that us humans are healthier when we
are smaller which is certain society
these transformation photos also
demonize the before photo as someone
that is not good enough just as they are
what does this content say about
somebody that looks like the before
photo it says you are not good enough as
you are and i have to go to extreme
lengths to not look like you and i'm
being celebrated for that
piggybacking onto
these photos belittle exercise simply
down to a weight loss tool but it is so
much more than that
it's not that much more than that
actually
pretty close
exercise is about getting healthier yeah
and transforming your body which if
you're overweight usually means becoming
less that
and if you're underweight
becoming less of that too in adding more
yeah the before picture wasn't just
snapped of you walking into a store
right it's something that you
volunteered for so you could show your
weight loss that's what you would think
well you would listen but people follow
me around with cameras all the time
that's the problem with smartphones yeah
they're not really phones it's just a
way for people to
make me feel ashamed of myself their big
brother they take the worst angles this
is this is not what fitness should i
love how by the way she puts on just
enough makeup to say i'm not i this is
me oh natural oh yeah i'm so nasty but
look she looks like a workout like
instructor like she's not the person to
be making this video in a mid-drift like
hey look at my abs by the way it's it's
not good for people we need a before and
after rhino just about getting more
market share right it used to be that
personal trainers people who were
fitness models or people who were
advocating health they only had access
to a market of people who wanted to
improve their health yeah now they're
saying well we can expand that market
share to people who don't want to be
healthy and we can just tell them that
they're wonderful the way they are so
you just what do you do it's more crap
from big tick tock yeah come in and take
a nap and that'll be your workout what i
don't understand she's into fitness it
looks like you know she's into fitness
but she's hitting this in her right now
this is why you said it was caffeine
earlier see how i stopped myself though
didn't actually say
you finished it in your head it's your
fault
so
this this happened last night uh
it's climate week did you know that
yeah i had no idea
no idea
which forced me to do a bunch of
research because i haven't brushed up on
global warming yeah it turns out that's
not
what it is anymore did you it's not
global warming oh okay is it what about
the other because it's not warming
oh yeah yeah so it's uh something else
give us your money climate change uh ish
that's changing the good thing is seth
meyers is here to explain it oh she was
good which is here's the thing too we
look we discuss things that are cultural
issues on this show yeah
in watching seth meyers i i realize this
guy will actually have state senators on
the program to try and actively push a
piece of legislation and then laugh
track it is so beyond the pale as far as
even attempting to be funny these really
are political pundits who have their
orders from the top down you have every
single late night host who got together
to try and make sure that you support
the green new deal here is every late
night host who exists i guess right now
our what we call our rear view mirror
competition discussing climate change do
you ever walk into a room as greta and
just want to talk about something you
watched on tv and people are like oh
greta tell us about the weather and the
climates and everything yeah
do you ever get tired of that
oh yeah who's next rich little don't get
me started i mean i'm so i'm so tired of
talking about the climate right now then
why don't you shut up
that's your thing billionaire what part
he's not trying to escape planet earth
on a spaceship at the moment thank you
all right so why is this a thing that
billionaires are obsessed with at the
moment bill what's your thoughts on it
massages by underage girls
i'd become obsessed with things like
malaria and hiv and you know getting rid
of those diseases
we have a lot to do here on earth
if you've been living pretty much
anywhere in the u.s i don't have to tell
you that the effects of climate change
are here and they are real you can see
it everywhere from wildfires and
droughts across the west to intense
storms in the gulf to flooding in new
york city which is why one climate
scientist prefers the phrase global
weirding and i personally think that's a
much more appropriate phrase because in
addition to wreaking havoc making the
planet uninhabitable climate change is
also making things much weirder oh oh
wow weird oh i tell you what the rapier
wit of seth meyers
ah wait he said fires in the west
and strong storms in the south so who do
we have let's stop laughing before we
get
yeah that's yeah it's just going to be a
problem
so you have jimmy kimmel jimmy fallon
stephen colbert james corden seth meyers
and i love how also samantha b joined in
she was like oh wait wait wait can i
fake like i'm not a lazy diversity hire
and do a show too like really you only
do four shows a year and one of them is
going to be the climate change week
samantha b
and seth meyers is the least a white
multi-millionaire yes he's a white
multi-millionaire female who's a
diversity hire specifically and this is
the issue
with samantha because they're like ah
because women aren't allowed to be funny
no no no don't speak for really talented
funny women like joan rivers or kathleen
madigan who didn't get a second look
because they weren't just willing to use
salon and slate unironically as
references you're a diversity hire
because you're a woman specifically
because you are not attractive in other
words they want to say look how
progressive we are we hired a woman you
thought we'd hire a woman you want to
see instead you're samantha bee and lazy
i've never seen anyone host fewer shows
than samantha she's like 10 shows a year
and collects millions of dollars wow so
how does it feel to be a diversity hire
exclusively because you are an unfunny
lazy
physically unpalatable female who's been
hand gifted a show that nobody watches
well it feels pretty good that you ask
me
come to think of it there's so many
people are we in a different topic i
have uh i have uh she i watched one
episode of hers honestly and that was it
and 20 minutes in it's just wow this is
a
giant propaganda machine just i was
waiting yeah i was waiting for funny
yeah i got like 15 minutes in and i'm
like i have not laughed yet what would
you expect funny
there was a perfect perfect uh parody of
the right right when he was on comedy
center it was actually fun anybody could
laugh at it i mean it was very funny yes
and then
i i don't understand here here's the
thing too it's very easy attack and by
the way i want to hear from you guys you
let me when was the last time you
actually watched late night more
importantly when was the last time you
watched late night on television that's
the big reason we started broadcast this
is more of a late night show in the
morning the reason was because we
noticed that when we used to air live at
night most people watched it the next
morning yeah
and i just said well i'm better in the
morning anyway because i'm too tired at
night i need my naps so
my my question is when was the last time
that you watched it and i know that it's
a very easy attack right this is what
the left will with with you or with
myself they're just not funny so
i don't want to do that what i want to
do is show you and the beauty is right
here we have an exact contrast of seth
meyers and us so you know when we came
back from the show we did a parody of
billy joel's we didn't start the fire
and joked about how hack it was that was
the joke uh seth meyers also did that
last night as part of his climate change
week so uh here we go side by side and
whether you're left or right
i think we i think we're better
wildfires powers down mayor is back in
east town bill gates divorced derby's
got a documentary
loser megan rappin oh piece of [ __ ] de
blasio hey look i think he pooped pfizer
versus jnj gavin newsom's a-okay nicki's
cousin's friend sacked gene smart's come
back brady had a big win rudy married
his cousin ryder is that the door i
can't take it anymore
[Music]
say what you will
12 writers and five emmy nominations
wow
let that sink in the sheer effort
displayed
and
look maybe let's say that you think this
you know
dave isn't funny which makes me know
that you're wrong and maybe you think
that this show isn't for you
at least we don't take you for gra what
offends me more than anything is when
when a host takes his audience for
granted yeah these people are taking you
for granted they don't expect you to
fact check them of course they don't
expect you to uh actually have a
standard as to the kind of content
that they should deliver that's the
issue at least we put an effort let's
say it sucks let's say they both suck
and it's wash well one put effort into
sucking
there's 12 people that thought that was
good
the people i don't know if they thought
you were talking about cats because
james corden was on there oh
everyone thought
i celebrated yeah you're right though i
mean the whole point of the weed insert
the fire thing that we had put together
was leaning into the hackiness of it
making it funny and then filming it as
if it was very very serious right
putting a bunch of effort into something
that doesn't warrant it yeah you know
comedy
he's embarrassed reading his do you
notice that yeah he's uncomfortable he
doesn't know if he should sing he
doesn't know what he doesn't know if he
if it's actually funny or if it's just
what happened he's just half-assing well
what is he going to do when someone
hands him goes look i have your billy
joel parody is he going to say hey i'm
not satisfied uh this mr pansexual asian
queer with ricketts he can't criticize
him yes this is great you're brave and
beautiful yeah fantastic
that's the problem with the diversity
comedy room by diversity higher comedy
room we really have look at the writers
look at look at the writers and compare
them to qualifications of say jon
stewart first guy who ever got me uh up
on stage was a writer for jon stewart a
canadian yeah it was very very funny
disagreed on everything politically uh
but this is so they're doing this for
climate week right all late night hosts
and just because we're kind of uh uh
contrarian um we're going to do our part
as well uh uh choice sauce is here and
he's going to bring him in yeah okay
he's actually going to be uh
all show
what are you going to be there doing
their choice house
so i'm here to do my part stephen i'm
here to do my part for climate so
this is going to be doing my part yeah
all show
yeah get some uh yeah get double yeah
yeah there you go some good cfcs going
there dual wheels
yeah just aim it away from me because
yeah expensive and the cu and your drink
yeah the cfc so i'll show is that the
stuff that gets sprayed in my eyes when
i expose myself yes okay just making
sure same rough it's felt
general oh
there's a variance depending on how uh
severe the exposure whoa that makes
sense keep spraying it oh geez yeah you
can't stop i'll i'll i'll show you the
holy spirit
and we'll check in later on that hole in
the ozone that's also a pandemic it
might be gone now um by the way the best
way to tune into the show is monday
through thursday it's a live show
10 a.m eastern 10 am eastern that's the
best thing you can do live he's not
going to stop jail get over it
for crying out loud still going he's
trying to lock it up proud lift it up
proud there you go what lactic acid
buildup i don't give a [ __ ] not on the
mic yeah
okay
uh monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern we're gonna be taking your chats
here at mod club afterwards and uh also
follow us on the podcast follow us i
already said that i thought that you hit
the overlapping i didn't hear so uh
i was about to move on to the other
story the next story oh because i am
i am uh vibrating with anticipation he's
still sprayed elliott paige has signed
up for the dating app raya
raya yeah okay uh and raya is an
invite-only site known it's known for
celebrity users uh an lh profile
includes a photo uh with
their dog and how am i supposed to say
ellie
well
by the way because now they re they
retroactively changed the imdb credits
to elliot page does that make michael
did michael sarah play a gay guy
yes
by the way it's by visibility today did
you know that oh oh well hey you know
what you don't need a day we can tell
out isn't bi just like code word for gay
now like i thought that's true i don't
know the whole thing is
buy and pan yeah buy and pan is a thing
pan just means that you can be anything
and attracted anybody i'm like oh so
it's bi like no no no it's not buying
like some some some karen out there
wanted like a subset like buy is not
good enough i need something that speaks
to me we need a visibility day because i
can't see them all year
it's like where's bi yeah
very by the way waldo's a dick waldo
knows exactly what he's doing is like ah
i don't know i'm not trying to be lost
like well really how many candy cane
forests are there waldo
you seem to find them all he seems to
find the miracle like i don't know i
always just uh hang out in my uh
peppermint lounge furniture
he'd go to some weird places yes he does
awful crowded for a guy who's trying to
be found yes
so elliot has had so much success on on
raya actually that uh z decided to
actually invest and uh now has equity
and a new startup dating app plenty of
ick so that's one
wow
[Laughter]
bye visibility day oh
good lord we see you
bye visibility do your job there quarter
black yard he just he's not even letting
people know he's not what are you
talking about that guy's uh the one guys
on the show my son watches called henry
danger
i know what he used to be a woman on
plentyvik.com you can date him ah
get a profile no
it's free yeah feel free to sign up i'm
on there
all right hello okay david yeah i know i
was waiting for you dave yeah because uh
it's it's you know what i can hear your
stomach crumbling oh i'm hungry yeah
okay well you know we have the built
bars in the studio if you're hungry out
there in the studio no i don't sorry
guys a little you guys can't hear
because we have the noise gate i can't
see his stomach rumbling so if it seems
weird i hear it
dude the last box or the last box of
built bars are in the scary temple down
the hall i'm not gonna go there by
myself okay all right not this well uh
okay i'll go i'll go with you all right
i'll be all right all right it's not
that big a deal all right we might die
guys no but that's okay
[Music]
there are so many cobwebs like my wife's
womb
you're not the first one to say that
jorge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time to argue throw me the
build bars
you have no choice
hurry
are you stupid
he's mine now
oh no dr jones
the competing bar is the little poison
[Music]
that's putting it mildly
wow oh man oh boy that was out there the
whole time yeah when did one of the one
of the cleaning ladies come
uh saturdays yeah we need to probably
make that a bi-weekly yeah fair
especially yeah that's ridiculous um
that's right you have the built bars uh
you can go to uh built.com use the promo
code crowder15. let me always i've said
i've been very clear about this no one
needs protein bars right
you put these things in the freezer
though they just taste like a candy bar
that's why i like they're pretty good
when i was after surgery and i cut out
crap i just ate these because it was
better than it was better than actually
just eating crap
and they're all you know they actually
have their whatever's called the
qualifications there so you actually
know the protein is what you're getting
in there they're just delicious in other
words you don't need them but if you
want to cut back in some sweets and eat
something that actually tastes good go
to built.com crowder15 and you get 15
off we use them all the time they're
delicious fantastic we really eat up
high we need to get some good uh
hondurans well just clean yeah clean yum
choy sauce just make sure you're not
spraying the you know the electrical
equipment yeah standing right in front
of you yeah yeah we want right we want
it in the air we want to harm the
environment i'm trying to get to the
ozone not end up like the thing in
poltergeist
so i kind of do there you go and i want
to hear from you guys we're going to
talk about this right now give me give
me a minute to explain this because this
is a big
uh this is this is a big situation so
you may not have seen this we weren't on
youtube
we weren't on youtube while we talked
about this yeah there is a supplement
out there uh called neck and
acetylcysteine it's an amino acid and
while we were live on air you've used it
for a long time uh yeah there we found
out that it was banned or i guess to
speak very clearly the fda had reached
out and threatened manufacturers who had
been carrying this or distributors for
many many years saying you can't carry
it because now it's a drug which is
unprecedented by the way it was some
kind of like head fake that they were
doing that really kind of scared some
people right but at the time of this
article coming out it the article was
reading like this is now banned amazon
has pulled it and you can't get it from
so just for people who missed it because
we weren't on youtube for these two
weeks this was this is available on
rumble this happened live on air and
that forced us to do some digging and uh
again you're not supposed to be able to
talk about these things but uh we will
do you remember the nac stuff that i was
telling you about that you take before
drinking yeah it's what they give you if
you overdose on right tylenol in the
hospital exactly right so they actually
just pulled that from being over the
counter i just learned about this just
the other day because we use this a lot
i i'm in the wine business and they've
made it prescription only now and the
theory behind it is that it actually is
somewhat helpful in treating some
symptoms maybe that you can get from
coven 19. really
you can't get nac as a stuff go look at
it now go i went to amazon yesterday
when i when i read this article go on
amazon or anywhere else right now and
google nac and you'll see it come up but
you'll see products that are not in ac
anymore you can no longer get that over
the counter and it's just it must be
very recent because i have it it was the
it was like it was yesterday so let me
be really clear about this this is
something and again we're not promoting
we're not saying zinc stops covid
so it turns out you may have been wrong
yes that it may not be banned but the
fda is heading towards banning it from
being a supplement now i'm i'm not a
doctor let me be really close is not
medical advice at the advice of my
doctor i have consistently throughout
covid and these are all things by the
way that you can
do in addition to mask vaccines yeah not
saying to do them in as a substitution
zinc quercetin which just helps my whole
goal has been to reduce viral
replication yeah uh in the body because
viral load affects your symptoms zinc
querstin you can read the clinical data
on that uh nac and i'll explain to you
why and just a xylitol uh nasal rinse
with saline solution that's it the whole
point is to reduce the viral load it
either worked for me to the point that i
was asymptomatic or i never caught it
because i was surrounded by people who
had cove in my family by the way they're
all fine i repeat myself
and it's not just for potentially
anything not just for other stuff right
absolutely cold and other things that
you might kind of run into the neck and
the vitamin d i didn't take vitamin d i
took zinc quercetin and a a saline nasal
spray with xylitol except i was watching
a pretty convincing video last night
again not a doctor youtube i just saw a
video putting it out there where they're
saying that it's really a vitamin d
deficiency that's causing us to have
these the immune problems yeah and that
there's not really a flu season or cold
season there's just low vitamin d
now here's the problem with that and
he's already seen the video
no but here's the problem with the
problem with that is there it's sort of
looking at a population correlation
right yeah low vitamin d and there is a
strong correlation for me any time i use
a supplement or any time i've got to
actually see the mechanism of action and
why it works in that scenario not just
going hey people with lower vitamin
lower vitamin d tend to get sick more
yeah
there's a mechanism of action with
knacks specifically
that relates to covid now you've been
familiar with it for people who don't
know i want to know people out there if
you've known about this if you've not
been able to purchase it again it this
we didn't plan on doing a deep dive into
this no but it's really concerning
um so what is it okay look let me
explain to you exactly what uh what what
knack is so knack is basically an amino
acid it's basically you could call it
like a derivative amino acid what it is
is um your body uses it to create this
thing called glutathione that's your
master antioxidant in your body okay
your body creates this antioxidant it's
at its highest concentrations in the
liver and it's also at high
concentrations in the lungs now there
are other arguments that it also has
immune modulating effects but the point
is knack actually you can bring this up
as an overlay and i'll show what people
find on youtube when they search for it
i drank a bottle of children's tylenol
as a kid
with my mom she was giving us medicine
tonight all done proud of me no you're
gonna die man what do they do in
hospitals they give you intravenous neck
it works it is medically used right
because it actually you've heard the
term detox no no your dandelion root
isn't going to detox you if you drink a
bottle of children's tylenol go to a
hospital they ivy knack to you and it's
the same reason that uh people who drink
like you do a lot of wine tastings knack
yeah helps protectively against the
liver that's how you keep exactly yeah
exactly this is how i found out about it
and honestly i was telling people like i
drink wine for a living it's too much
dave i know but still too much one one
glass a day or something like that i
still take it every single time but
there are other times where i drink more
i actually was pushing this to my
clients i was like take this this will
help you out immensely even if you only
have a glass it's just good for liver
health and a nurse fact check me she
pulled up her phone and goes oh yeah
they do give it to you in the hospital
if you go in with an overdose
weird weird yeah you brought a lot of
knack though and i i did look i just
think the time that we bring this yeah
another yeah in other words it's not the
problem with knack it's that knack is a
symptom of something
much more severe what is what's
happening gerald uh we're not actually
on the live show today you know what
this is an intervention and
didn't you notice when the red blinking
light wasn't on
do you think we'd waste this much time
on air with him spraying cfcs it makes
no sense this is a lot of cover is do i
have a problem well see we think you do
and i'm glad that you asked because the
answer is yes i have a problem and we
think that
in fact you sat here yesterday and the
seat is quite uncomfortable
and it's oh oh see
yeah oh come on
not all the neck in the world isn't
going to it's good
man i know this was you i sat on two
wine bottles today in my car yeah try
and blame it on travis trit yeah it
wasn't him
one of the one bottles was mine yeah
well that's another issue no we this is
an intervention but we actually are on
here so we get the best of both worlds
here's the thing if you travel i mean
get help if you try and research knack
on youtube yeah right
the algorithms are supposed to be really
smart oh you are trying to take health
care into your own hands right right
what they say yeah betty ford you would
think no instead this is the
third result right now on youtube bill
nyx
i sentence you to five years in montero
state prison
get the kids out
[Music]
i gotta be honest unbelievable
today's the day
put it down put it down i know you
commit to the character
oh it's this is about youtube will think
that it's more what i'm about to do
which is educating you from clinical
data is more dangerous or more
subversive
than uh uh
anal gay sex in a shower
in a prison which by the way is how you
get things that make you sick
so if we're talking about health say
them way down the list should be gay sex
in the shower you know what you you
rarely see in the the gay shower rape
dancing you don't see a lot of lights
they don't break out in songs it's not
really celebratory well that's also
there doesn't need to be the dance of uh
of of romance
you know as a the man weaves his
tapestry of charm it's just
are they wearing
they're wearing pink for breast cancer
awareness month
you don't need a whine and you know if
lil noss is in the shower like that you
don't need to whine and dine them you're
pretty much at the finish line folks
locked in i think after two three days
in jail you just need a man's touch
a little nausea is like they're gonna
send me to prison
yeah all he hears is you get 20 years in
heaven
[Laughter]
we're going to sentence you to
all your weekends only forever yeah
um so going back to this is what happens
if you try and find information on it as
a matter of fact the article that we
quoted on there now can't be found you
have to go through the internet time
machine yeah so let me be really clear
about this great way to get you to stop
looking it's a great way to get you to
stop looking i'm kidding so it was um
it's been used in medicine since 1968
this thing neck okay was prescribed for
chronic lung disorders at one point so
like bronchitis pneumonia
like i said it's been used in the
hospital for actual detox as it relates
to the liver um
look here's here's what it's uh what it
actually affected it's been used
effectively in things like copd lung
pneumonia and you know lung infections
yeah why because this master antioxidant
that your body creates glutathione is
created in the liver uses neck to create
it and it's very concentrated in the
lungs think of it think of it as a
natural mucinex it's an expectorant okay
it loosens it and so what does that do
it reduces a viral load in your lungs
you expect he's especially good at
expectorating
who by the way also probably spent a lot
of time in the shower well you know goss
protests too much
yes gaston loosens and load uh so cystic
fibrosis copd inhalation injuries um
these were and you can we have a link
right here national academy of sciences
we have links at pubmed um it has a
proven track record of limiting liver
damage it's as a matter of fact often
uses a protocol for people who've known
people who've taken drugs that could be
damaging to your liver knack is the
first thing people go to yeah so even
for example that's how i found out about
it when they would have me on these uh
antibiotics and steroids and i said well
what actually is clinically effectively
proven to protect your liver yeah
there's a lot of crap out there that
doesn't do anything it's clinically
proven and been used in hospitals nac
beyond any shadow of a doubt in other
words this is the kind of thing
that the fda should be happy about
because there's a lot of fairy dusting
the supplement world where there's a lot
of snake oil salesmen this is something
that we know works and this is something
we know has been used for a very long
time and now the fda is saying oh it's
so effective uh we're going to collect
we're going to say it's a drug
it's not a supplement yeah and i i don't
know i mean at the fda i'm not sure
exactly what they're thinking they don't
have a great track record with stuff
right you know sometimes they've
approved some really bad drugs but
how do you scare the hell out of amazon
that much to where they pull it from
both amazon and whole foods right right
with some kind of letter and why this
should be something you're shouting from
the mountaintops everybody in the
alcohol industry that i talked about
this had no clue and everybody's worried
because you drink wine for a living and
you're like i don't want my liver to
become a fatty liver and have a problem
right why isn't this being like shouted
from oh just knocking stuff over here
yeah why don't you just shout it out why
why i'll tell you exactly why this and
this is just me i cannot
i can't prove that this is the exact
reason why but i can prove
what it does
how it works what the fda is doing and
what is happening at the exact same time
that they sent out these notices also
like the opposite of the vaccine yeah
like the opposite so the fda sent a
letter to a manufacturer's company
saying you have to stop you have to stop
selling neck
wow right because it was approved as a
drug in 1963 and then because it is a
very it's very has a very wide
therapeutic window what does that mean
that means that generally speaking if
you take more of it unlike tylenol if
you take three pills too many you damage
your liver if you take too much of this
supplement your body excretes it
right so it's effective and safe
and then i did some digging okay
and um this is a law that's rarely
rarely used i think it was in 1963 it
was a drug and then it became a
supplement and this is unprecedented
where the fda is a drug drug like that
that was an actual drug a prescription
okay so again i'm not no one can say
this is misinformation because the fda
has said this is a drug and they have
classifications that have to prove
efficacy for it to be a drug the fda
said actually it's not a supplement it's
a drug it was a drug in 1963. now it's
been a supplement for decades and
they're pulling it as a supplement
saying actually it may need to be
classified as a drug which they don't do
ever this is unprecedented for something
to go from drug to available supplement
to drug
so that you guys can't have access to it
yeah and by the way incredibly cheap so
incredibly yeah
not for long so no it'll get there
we know that it's concentrated in the
lungs we know that cove detects the
lungs
did some research you guys can dive
around on pubmed yeah
knack was found to reduce the expression
of tumor necrosis uh the tumor necrosis
factor and pro-inflammatory cytokines
which contribute to the eventual
cytokine storm
seen in severe covid19 here's something
else knack specifically scavenges the
peroxides released by white blood cells
which can then cause enema and further
lung injury there was a portion of
coveted patients uh uh well a portion of
let me set this up they require
ventilator that's a really bad thing
some people argue it's a death sentence
there's some doctors who say
ventilator's a bad idea there are some
doctors who say uh it's a good thing to
use in these hospitals a lot of doctors
think that we're going to them too early
i'm not a doctor but there are differing
opinions in the medical community nack
was found to be useful as a prophylaxis
agent
against forms of pneumonia and it
reduced the incidence of ventilator
associated pneumonia by about 20 so down
from 46 to 26
that's why the fda is saying it's a drug
because it's clinically effective enough
to reduce being put on a ventilator and
it's safe and it's cheap and it's
available bam
think about that for a second
unbelievable because you're right on the
ventilator we had a somebody that we
know their husband was on a ventilator
and were like oh gosh like it's a death
sentence you know like so but this is
like the one time where they didn't they
came off and we're like what yeah like
they came off so we were shocked because
we thought it was over right but listen
pneumonia is not exactly new like no
it's not new people that's how this was
developed was for people with pneumonia
bronchitis we should have been using
this forever for this stuff because the
flu typically pneumonia is one of the
biggest killers of people who get the
regular flu yes right so again i make my
point again why is this not in a
billboard why is this not like fluoride
in our water there's also been some some
research that shows that knack may
specifically inhibit covert by binding
up to an enzyme and interfering with the
virus replication so again all of these
things now none of these things are uh
entirely proven as far as the covet
stuff yeah we do know it's proven to
help with liver damage we do know it's
proven to help with your lungs that it
was a prescription available the fda
says it's an effective drug as an
expectorant for your lungs we do know
that it has a very high safety threshold
and therapeutic window we know all these
things and we know that the fda started
saying you better stop selling this
snack otherwise we're going to come
after you to the point where every
company that i know online stopped
selling it except for swans and vitamins
right they were all scared into silence
and this just so happened to coincide
with go to clinicaltrials.gov a phase
two clinical trial with 160 something
patients for knack and kovac how much
you want to bet your sorry ass they're
going to find some methylated derivative
of this and sell it as a as snack and
it'll be the new covid truck
because keep in mind a vaccine can only
be approved under the emergency
authorization act if there is no
available therapeutic none wouldn't it
suck if there's a available therapeutic
that's five dollars a bottle that you
guys declared the fda declared so
effective it needs to be classified as a
truck
that's incredible i i don't and i don't
think we're uh we're too far out here
either because when you like i said when
you see amazon doing this when you see
other companies i think you're right
like i tried to go buy some of this
stuff right as this was happening and it
was very much not available yeah only i
went to swanson's i loaded up on it just
the other day we started talking about
this again food truck not the food
trucks the vitamin plates they're
getting a lot of free plugs from us
right now yeah we gotta talk to these
guys about uh coming on board so is the
food truck
i don't think there's a food truck that
we should worry about no but they i get
it if there's no reason for amazon to
pull a part of their business and piss
off a part of their customers because
those people are represented by an
agency that wrote a letter to the fda
and said what are you doing and the fda
basically says oh we hadn't changed we
hadn't changed our stance yeah but we
just scared the hell out of amazon we
just scared the hell out of people and
we
we took unprecedented action this is
what i talked about yesterday with
conspiracy theories it's how many people
need to be there yeah right area 51
the jews running all the things the
point is how many people need to be
they in this case it's bank the fda
makes a call to three people bezos
apple yeah and then says by the way uh
zuckerberg and just just make sure you
don't allow this information to travel
if someone searches uh for a way to take
their health into their own hands and
they're actually looking for something
with clinical data that has been proven
beyond any shadow of a doubt show them
guys having anal sex in the shower and
pink rubs that's what we think is the
best
approach
they will call evil good and good evil
but this happened on air and i was going
why the hell could they bend that i
don't unders
well i thought i got it wrong like i
really did i thought i was i was because
we were talking about it and i was like
that article said it right at the time
and then we go back to the article and
it's completely different i don't know
if we have an overlay for it or not but
it's a completely different article it
completely changed the article it's
changed twice though gibbon told me this
morning he went out and pulled it up and
he's like oh something on biden and then
he pulled it up again right before the
show he's like it's a completely
different article now not related
they're changing meanings though they're
changing everything they're changing
meanings and this was scary and there's
i've always been out of the business of
attributing motive and i want to hear
from you guys anyone out there who's
used necro this is your first time
hearing about it nac yeah um
they're not claiming that it's dangerous
they're not claiming hey don't put this
on the label because you can't make uh
just this medical claim for example
they're saying with a hangover cure you
can't say cure but in other words you
can put oh this supports
liver health and lung function because
it's proven in clinical data that's rare
in a supplement the fda is not saying
hey you can't sell this because it's
dangerous they're saying hey you gotta
stop because it's effective
they're not looking out for you these
people don't care about you in other
words let's say it doesn't work that
well that's not what the fda says right
they want to reclassify it as a drug
let's say it works somewhat but it's
incredibly safe and it's been used for
decades
why should you have the choice removed
from you that's what's so scary to me is
the choice is removed from you we don't
believe that you should have control
over your own health and if you look at
socialized healthcare you look at the
proposals from the left do any of these
proposals involve putting more control
in your hands and and more weight into
the relationship directly between you
and your doctor no no they put they put
more uh
more of not hsa they put more health
insurance companies between you they put
higher premiums they put more
bureaucracy more red tape these people
make a ton of money and if there's
something that's available that your
doctor can recommend which has happened
with things like nac
they make sure that you don't have
access to it there is no reason for this
to have taken place and the fda and the
government have not even argued that
they're doing this for your safety
they why are they doing it they haven't
argued why they're doing it at all no
all we know is that it's entering
clinical trials now and it seems to make
sense kind of like you were telling with
the vitamin d i go well that's looking
at a that's looking at a population
making an inference
no the reason this is entered into
trials is because people have said oh
here's an actual scientific mechanism of
action that seems like it could be very
effective
with covid and it makes sense if we go
oh what it what we use it for with copd
with pneumatic infections how we use it
to help avoid ventilators where they
often would use it as an adjunct therapy
they're going oh we know we specif we're
not just looking at people who consumed
more knack in their diet we're looking
at people who are using this as an
effective medication or supplement and
we've found a mechanism of action that
may help protect the population at large
from this pandemic
make sure it's not available as a
therapeutic because that might affect
the emergency authorization yeah and by
the way the fda they may go oh well look
we're not banning it we're just we're
just telling companies that if they sell
it they're going to come under further
scrutiny yeah yeah that's basically what
amazon was worried about was further
scrutiny from the fda and so you can go
that's like a software no they can still
sell it on their personal websites right
these other companies that are making it
yeah but if you effectively take away
the market for it and scare enough
companies you maybe i don't know walmart
i think search somebody searched and
said hey i might be able to find it
there how how long is it until walmart
goes oh crap do we want further scrutiny
from the fda do we want those guys
coming in that are unqualified and
saying ah sorry your business is doing
some things that we don't like so all
you have to do is make sure that it is
completely almost unavailable by normal
channels right amazon one of the biggest
channels obviously right walmart right
behind those guys oh swanson oh hey
swanson's uh you got a pretty good
business here guys we really like we
hate to come in and have to scrutinize
that yeah we'd hate to have to come in
like bill gates with baseball bats
exactly like windows
and this is a shame if something
happened to you
it would be a real shame if that uh
benign uh effective amino acid that was
available as an over-the-counter
supplement for decades were rammed up
your ass oh geez yeah you wouldn't like
that wouldn't like that would you mr
bezos if we uh go up there with the
sigmoidoscopin imax ratio now
it's a beautiful penis rocket moon river
this is straight to space and this is
where i hope people are starting to look
i'm a conservative i don't say
who appeared no i'm a conservative why
because i believe in a limited
government intervention and i don't like
the fda and cdc but i do hope that
people see this right now as far as the
game being rigged with elites against
you think about this for a second the
fda these people they go after and
rightfully so most supplements are
[ __ ] let me be very clear
you can count on both hands the amount
of supplements that actually do anything
this happens to be one of them because
it was originally a prescription most of
them are [ __ ] that's not lost on me
but the fda comes down on companies for
making claims as a supplement company
and they'll say you can't make those
claims because it's not clinically
proven right and then if it's clinically
proven they come down them and say well
then it has to be classified as a drug
how do you how do you take care of your
own health
how do you do anything this is something
when people talk about it on youtube and
they say there's conspiracies and you
know howard stern speaking of sellouts
howard stern going after joe rogan it
seems like they all i don't know if they
all had a meeting behind our back
um
going after joker i was taking a horse
to woman no this is an actual medication
whereas the conspiracy for taking these
this medication why would you guys why
would you guys take any of these
alternative treatments is what a doctor
would say hold on a second hold on a
second alternative to what
what treatment right now
is available aside from the rationing
regeneron of course yes of course
because keep in mind that a lot of
people needing these antibody treatments
have been vaccinated yeah yeah that's a
statistical fact you wouldn't need to
ration it run the numbers if vaccinated
people didn't also seek out antibodies
right now but alternative let's just say
something like ivermectin yeah let's
call it an alternative therapy
alternative to what if you already test
positive for covid right now not talk
about preventative vaccine you go to a
hospital
what treatment
hey this pain we don't want to push as
an alternative
to alternative treatment yeah
alternative to what
go into a hospital right test positive
for covid
they will give you no treatment they'll
give you maybe an inhaler to help with
the symptom and once they get bad enough
they'll put you on a ventilator which
may or may not kill you faster depending
on which doctor you ask or study you
reference there is no alternative
treatment because this is the first
virus the first disease in our lifetime
where it seems that not no one is
interested in possible treatment
and as a matter of fact the people are
supposed to be looking out for you are
making sure that there can be nothing
available for you as far as treatment
and that's scary it's absolutely scary
and it all started because of a guy with
orange hair
like that's that's the whole reason for
this it seems is because he came out and
said hey there's these things that might
be helpful and every time we said
something about that they would pull up
a fish tank cleaner story and be like
see see that's a problem we can't do
that oh see he said inject bleach into
your skin nope we can't do that and it's
like no that's not what i'm saying i'm
just saying maybe there's some things
that can help
treat people who right now are dying
with no hope that's how disingenuous the
media is because you know maybe there's
subway to get some uh some of these
disinfectants you know internally he
said did you just hear inject bleach
into your veins you heard bleach iv
correct no because i'm not dishonest or
[ __ ] it's not even close to what he
was saying no no but these are the same
people so you kind of this goes full
circle right so these are the same
people that say you have to have
government health care because the
government's going to do it better
medicare for all then they say oh well
you have government health care well now
we're going to start looking at you
different if you don't have a vaccine
and you come into the icu and i've got
to pick between you and somebody who did
get the vaccine and they did take the
proper steps i'm sorry you're just not
going to get the icu bit we see video
after video after video of people saying
that in the medical community that are
pissed off and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
wait what about people who come in that
have made really bad decisions about
their health in other ways yeah and now
how about if you're a fat doctor i kick
you in the balls and see how well you
exactly see what happens to you then but
these are the these people want you to
have want the government to have all the
control of your health and then they get
to tell you just like you warned about
canada when we had obamacare coming out
they get to tell you what's important oh
you're gonna have to wait six months for
that treatment because we don't have
enough people for it and maybe you
didn't make good decisions for my mother
it was 14 months for an mri when she
broke her back yeah
this is the reason we were as canada
calls it an elective it didn't take long
bernie we got there
this is really we're at a point right
now where i think that a lot of people
and i'm wondering where all the all the
naturalists and all the people who
didn't trust big pharma went to yeah
where's bernie sanders
this is the biggest
19 billion dollars i don't have this we
can bring this up as a source here i'll
have it available at a lot of credit.com
and click the references
uh pfizer 19 billion dollars was that a
quarter in q2 what in the second quarter
that's over 200 million a day but you
know what else
they're blood thinning medication that
may be used also for clots the sales
went up
double digits guess what they're drug
available for people who have heart
complications for example maybe
something like myocarditis we don't know
went up over 70 percent as far as sales
not only that and we'll have all of
these i'm just going by wrote here they
fought off a patent law for their
anti-clotting drug where no one will be
able to do a generic until 2028. guess
what else they thought what's the name
of that heart drug from pfizer vive viv
vinerin vance or no not violence it's v
something and it costs 250 000
and they're actually right now putting a
bill
before the house to make it paid for by
medicaid oh jeez
so that's a that's a brilliant ploy
doesn't matter how well these things
work if they're funded by the government
that's not a free market that's 19
billion dollars of your money as far as
i'm concerned we all own the patent i
this is my issue with big you want to
develop a drug great develop a drug and
i think you should be as profitable as
you see fit my issue is when
you make that profit at the expense of
the taxpayers yeah it's not a free
market and the people in power right now
are doing the bidding of these companies
there is nothing wrong with a free
market economy for new drugs and medical
developments there is something
incredibly wrong with the fda being in
charge of what you can do with your own
body acknowledging that something is
effective that you have access to
pulling it and then making sure that we
funnel tens of billions of dollars per
quarter into a company for vaccine that
seems to reduce hospitalizations and
severity but doesn't do what many people
thought it did that's why you're pissed
off you wouldn't be pissed off if
someone else wasn't vaccinated if you
weren't
[ __ ] and thought that it would affect
you
[Music]
actually austin
i don't know how to tell you this but
one of the deepest and largest holes
ever
in the ozone layer actually um
closed
oh it closed what yeah i know that's why
i'm doing this i mean asians are one of
the biggest contributors to carbon
emissions i need to do my part in this
reopen it but that's
opening i don't want to speak in
generalizations but they are that's an
example of an industrious people we're
going to talk more about this and take
your chats uh we have to go sorry for
the rant youtube thank you you know what
do what this what you may
fact-check me bro piss off
i